You can go and get off there.
I'm going to do that.
We're going to take your taxi into Barcelona.
I'm trying to read it.
I'm from the United States of America, and in the Jewish public, or which it stands, one nation under God, into this world with liberty and justice for our own.
That's great.
Following that, we thank you for another beautiful day, experience your goodness and grace, and we pray that your hand would be upon each and every one of us.
Board that you have gotten to direct our actions, our words, that they would be honorable in your sight and pray the work for the activity of our county.
We pray for the work that's being done here in this building and surrounding buildings.
For the benefit of this county and pray that it was in the discernment of all decisions made.
We just pray that you keep your hand upon all of our elected officials as well as our workers.
We can keep that safe and healthy.
We bless our families and protect them.
I continue to unite our county together and call me good as we work together for the good ball.
Thank you for your love and your friends and your watch here over season.
Everyone, so I'm going to come to us.
I have not had a question.
Max, last time I was here, I was thinking about the right lane.
I didn't have the right timing, just want me to see where I'm going.
If you had talk.
I did look at that.
And here, you're right.
Here's a break ahead.
The line is just stopped over there.
I talked to our road woman.
And one of the problems we run into with
doing something like that and the total roof shape and area is when it rains.
That's already the problem is water.
And if you loosen it up and roof shape, there's water that they know above the hill.
So then this story is everything you try to do.
So it's a long-term project.
We just very gradually move it.
But who's aware of it?
We talked about it.
They repositioned that tube when they put it in so that we can accept that water better so we don't watch it for a while.
And is that clay?
Is it warm in nature?
And then do we have a more experienced greater in lay County or in Lawson when the others do you know if we're like our best greater is?
And could we get some of the newer in-experience guys to come when we do things like that?
To learn something guys who
are trying through an experience of now.
I understand what you're saying, but we're doing our best to train people as we go right now.
We're just trying to ban the great ash of this area because, like yesterday, I went through different calls and so on.
We're going to need to be maintained and then put it in two, being at a door to have children in the drug.
People will be training because they're going to have the knowledge of how to do that.
So trying to keep everything going.
at the same time that you're training, that you're going to.
So someone has said that they're having like 15 or 16 or 40s on the rate coming from, and that was only like five.
Well, they're used to be five.
We're more, I'm not sure how many we have, but I think we probably won't be 10.
We're looking for 12 right now as a start, and see how that works for us instead.
So we're hiring.
Yeah.
And then it's on the salt.
We are.
We have questions about our father.
Because the day you came in, I had a question to ask him.
Did you then tell him who he was?
So Chad Stockton was the only one.
We've been talking to him.
So I called him and he didn't know.
But he did tell me it was him what they were had to do, which it was.
First off, he's going to take a minimum of weeks to two days to do.
During that time, my office will not have a bathroom.
There's also going to be, both of those walls have to be cut out completely to be known that you've been either direction.
So what about all the S Festus in and like paint about them?
Because I can't be around even cheaper off-dust.
That's one of the nine severely elected two.
Angie has about a conclusion.
She cannot be around anything like that.
My others, and I talk to the others.
We have about one peer-roundity asbestos for let paint dust.
So how about us all that going to be?
And the asbestos is going to have special treatment.
You came to us as for a bathroom.
You tell this all began.
Next in 2017.
OK. We weren't there today.
I'd asked I'd asked for it.
Yeah, right here as well as the one that we're paying.
Yeah, there's that to get that done for you.
Right.
And this is the first time we've heard these issues.
I'm not aware of that because of that tape.
This may be there.
I don't know.
We'll have to look into it.
He's pretty positive there will be because the building was built in 1954.
Well, he didn't mention the building.
Okay.
So this first time we could meet.
even taking that part out because if that's being owned, if he has to send it up to be tested, then it has to be back separately, put in the separate from start and all of that.
But what are we supposed to do with the bathroom for weeks and days?
There is.
They don't always work, and they lead badly, which causes flooding down in the air.
So, we're going to fix this on top.
Is that everything?
I don't know.
These are brand new tests today, but I have to look at all these things.
Okay.
Well, I've been using these for some of the things that we talked about before.
Every time somebody, we have not done it.
We have done it.
We have
Yes, the growing record.
Which also then one knows the two foot is going to happen to that office area where we do all the copying and everything like that.
We have to have the huge table in there.
We have to have all kinds of stuff.
But for a week to 10 days, you want to go down 20 concrete steps.
She is the back of those that don't currently work without leaking.
What would be your solution?
You told me it was about 5,000 hours difference.
What happens if you get on there and there's a specialist in the cost of 10,000 people in that?
Well, I do want that, but I tend to, during that whole time, the key chair says out and has to reach the start, we're going to have to be able to put that out by our office.
I'm on it.
I'm asking if I can get the sick.
But it works right now.
The bathroom upstairs works.
It's just, you have to start out of the toilet to shut the door.
Okay.
We're driving it.
We're driving it
That could complicate that.
It would have been easier just to move the background to the toilet out of the old bathroom and be done.
Because that was just, you know, we'll put the shelves in there to whatever's in that kitchen area goes in there.
We still have the seat in there.
It's just not as big.
We're not turning down the walls.
We're taking off the door and it's a new bathroom.
So we wouldn't be out of a bathroom at any point in time.
There wouldn't be any rest of us, best of us, for like paint dust.
a woman to shut the office down.
It just, when you think about that, it's best if it's on the left hand, just the cleanup part that has to be done.
or with that.
I could end up costing so much more than $5,000.
I understand right now we've talked about it, but we don't have attitude to show them.
Well, those are some of the things that we are very concerned about.
So I don't know.
You can just ask him those questions.
He wasn't sure, but I went ahead and asked him if he did it once this, this is, he said yes.
Those are great concerns.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'll talk to him.
I can't keep us in the mood so we kind of know what's going on.
Until we get further down the road, there won't be much to share and get there and make a decision yet.
Because I just, I want to be kept up today and I want to go on.
So when we make, when we get close to making a decision, I brought you the plan to have a discussion and told you where we were at so that you could get a comment and we wouldn't do that again.
Please, you didn't bring me anything like that.
No, I didn't bring it like that.
I told you what's planned was.
Absolutely.
Thank you for coming.
Okay.
But nothing has been arranged or nothing has been passed.
Again, once we get closer and we discuss this, it will bring me in blue.
But right now, I'm going to ask you a little question.
Something, and what's he going to be replacing the hot water heater or something, you have this hot water?
Yes.
Right now, there's like you have to get warm water.
Thank you.
Anyone else have any comments or any?
I would just hear in case you have questions about.
I saw it.
I didn't know there was something that I didn't be here for or not.
Well, it was just one of the proposals that I sent.
Yeah.
So I just, if you had any other questions, why?
I don't think so.
I have not looked at the wash, but I will be working on that.
And the other, the other windows should be taken and they're forward.
So he said 35 business days, so hopefully he got the end of the week.
And the other was on the rail, so I was ready to get that part of the agenda and picture.
OK. OK. OK. We need to review the minutes, and I have not.
I have not.
OK.
Thank you very much.
to good news for the day as we are making progress on concrete.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Bye.
And we take progress on this for winning.
When we finish up with this, we'll go down to the April 10th, so you won't have to waste your time.
We'll wait for this.
Thank you very much.
That's a really good one.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, I think we're ready to talk about the people too.
So I know you kind of went through this two weeks ago.
Why don't you refresh our memory on everything?
It's in the minutes, I think, of the discussion.
But I'm also interested in what you think about all of them is you.
I honestly don't, I can't tell you, from what I can't, about once a week.
I'm not sure that it's even that much.
It is, well, what we're asking for is the entry simply right now to $175 and we're asking for an increase to $2.25 with 50 of that coming back to the senior board, which is what governs the spending for the people to are for the senior center.
reasoning is just to help with offset some of the costs that belong along with maintaining the tables, chairs, ice machine, pitching equipment, that kind of thing.
that 225 keeps it pre-welling line and competitive with other facilities like religion or I think the idea of the idea of religion.
It's 3.25 I think.
I think it's still even at 225 it's a bargain.
I call it Lafayette County and talk to talk to them at Lafayette County.
I talk to
He begins to build their community center, and most of those are rented by the hour, where ours is on a weekday you get it from like four to midnight, and all weekend you get it, I think, eight to midnight.
So it's a bargain even at 225 compared to other facilities.
My question would be, and it might be from the West.
How do we do this?
Well, I don't think you pay every time that you read it.
I don't, that would have put just more work a lot of load on them.
I mean, you could do it on a quarterly, on a binary, on an annual basis, and then just, yeah, just pet it, check it.
Kathy has my understanding, Kathy tracks the rentals on it anyway.
And so then we would just have whatever those rentals are and calculate what and then pay.
However, you guys decide where they decide, you know, whatever makes it easy.
We don't want to be a problem with it.
We just want to, we would like to be able to see some of that come back to us to help us.
Like everyone else, we're budget constraints too.
So.
And I think I made the problem.
That's good.
We just want to be sure that we follow the right process for auditing purposes, whether it should be done to a supervisor.
We can do that.
I would say that the clerk's office probably has the best answer, works best for them, what works best from a legal standpoint.
I don't have a problem with the $50, you know, going to the senior board.
I think we should have some kind of agreement in writing.
I don't find it.
That defines exactly what it is.
You're going to do with that money on the maintenance items.
Right.
Well, we don't have a question later.
From our treasurer standpoint, it's probably easiest if we just went into our like the very term general fund, it's the levy account.
which is the same account that the money from the senior tax credit goes into anything outside of our market payment goes into that account.
So it would basically just go into general purpose.
Because I mean, that $50 for those rentals, it's not going to cover.
I mean, we just had a repair refrigerator for $12 a dollar.
So that's
What I am concerned about is who pays for the refrigerant would that be the print caddy or is that the same thing that's a part of the building like the walk in in the food room where so walk in freezer the walk in cooler the air conditioning HVAC systems that kind of thing that is county that's part of the building and if anything that is
The tables, the chairs, the kitchen utensils are in the kitchen appliances.
That comes to us.
That came, I got that information from the
That one time you gave me, I think it was you that gave me a list of what all the county covers on the eagle tent.
Yeah, I believe so.
So you guys have that?
Is that what you're talking about?
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
That's what you're talking about.
Okay.
So we've won a motion that we're going to have before us at a later date and agreement for us to sign to raise this and how the funds will be added.
So do I need to talk to you?
You guys about how that needs to be written up, who do I, or do you guys want to write it up and submit it to us?
We'll talk to Melissa and the clerk's office, but I think both of them will have to come up.
Okay.
And then let's know, and, uh, surely, and probably out myself, would sign it.
I don't have a problem.
We just want to get paperwork in order, and then we'll go from there.
Okay.
All of us, and thank her for taking that.
Good.
Just let me know.
Okay.
All right.
Appreciate it.
Okay, did you have something on the card?
I'm going to email for you.
Is this a new email address?
Cut, cut, quote, at PMMe.
I was just, because this is a new email address.
So I just want to make sure this was a good one for you.
Okay, so we've got that.
I'm sorry, what is the part of the county, the county, the trusted reason for the military conservation, so there's some rooms that we will go and put rock down for them, and then we get reinforced the portion of the work.
It's emery here, we'll be back.
We'll reach out.
This is a conservation area.
Yeah, let me down.
Let me do it.
I think you're welcome.
And then we have asked us a couple of weeks ago about this.
And when we received that,
Yeah.
And we will start on the only thing what those bits numbers are during the session, and then you don't have to chase that perfect thing.
Did you see that he's on the public in the local park?
I have a chance for you to ask the question that's a work.
Changing up from
That's what we thought.
That's what we were thinking to think that I wanted to double chair.
And we're going to call all of the members.
I just didn't want to take my word, I left right again.
Okay, perfect.
I got this.
You don't believe me?
You don't believe me.
How are you?
Okay.
With all that work, how long did the meeting go to the other night?
What's up with a lot of much?
No, it's really, really, you don't mess the panel that well.
So, I'll ask you guys, do you know what the meeting at Armourica is?
Burr, burr, burr, burr, burr, burr, burr?
No, I learned something every day here, though.
Squirrel.
That's what I was told.
I didn't Google it the very high, but it's the name of the class.
So really, yeah.
So I share a little good.
Take a bit of nothing.
because we have squirrels just watch more and we have squirrels.
Maybe you hear what just happened in my bar?
Yes, yeah.
Not good.
No, it makes me want to.
set out on my front porch with a 22 and pick them off.
Twice, I cut stress in my house.
Oh, I'm in, and I will tell you, the tour.
I'm just going to try the way, and I can see my big window that the curtains were hanging down.
I got somebody that had been up front and in, so I called the neighbor and just had this out of town.
They got inside.
They had got them.
I mean, it was all.
Had to call the neighbor came up to cut the others.
We trapped it in the towel.
We were running around trying to do that.
Okay, now that would have been worth the video.
We couldn't find it.
We knew it was in there.
And so, I'll, like, a day later, I came back every time the day later, I thought they'd get work back up the, you know,
and the squirrel died under a bed.
I saw it, and my kids saw it, they said, that squirrel looked out, so mom, go for a season.
I'm out of here.
Okay.
We've learned some new things today.
We'll go in.
I was in on the verb or a verb.
Oh.
Yeah.
So that's a very small.
I'll go get her in a pinch.
I did very fine.
Yeah, I'll go get her in a pinch.
I'll go get her in a pinch.
I don't know if you don't get them one at a time and they do it a simply line because I'm the president of this.
Okay, do you want us to come down there?
Or do you want to get y'all going up there on the line?
I don't know, pretty much.
Pretty bit space.
One, two, shake and make a verse that was very dangerous.
because they were, when everything that Baker had been taken, because we've got like a Baker's 80, and a Baker really, Baker, we've got one, you know, I think.
Well, they wasn't sure that would be, I don't know why.
Again, it's a pretty clear one so far.
I think that was better than the wise ours farms.
I thought that was good.
Yeah.
His belt is named every business.
Why have you?
Why have you seen him?
Yeah.
Wise ours.
This guy walks and walks down here off the wall of circle and he put them all together and they get somebody so they can get his hands on this one to make one big walk for himself.
We've been ready to go to the house up on this floor.
Okay.
We're close.
Circle.
South of, you know, the end of this clock row 10.
Okay.
Did you hear that?
That's a little one, too.
there.
I have to recap a new one.
So this one, this one was two separate locks.
They split together.
This lock was two, yeah.
And they put it back together and then back down for multiple.
So they put it into the bottom of it.
Same knock off all of it here in the team.
You can't go in one direction or the second.
I have a different line of follow-up slides.
I think that's it.
It would be a dream come true, but that would be getting every surveyor to this morning.
that now they pulled your foot around.
And then I said, so which did you open the name?
And she said, well, this is the last name.
And it means oral and purification.
And I said, I will forever.
And we believe it.
And they already said, what other things?
I am there.
Was it April full today?
I'm not sure that they didn't tell us something like that or they would.
Where were you?
Yeah, where do you thought you were funny on?
I thought Paula was really funny on April Fool's Day when she came down and we said we're not sure in that phone phone.
You will, you are rewarded.
Exactly.
It was because of you, you were the president, and you said I think it was a great idea.
So I'm going to have a nice day out there, and her face was just quite splitting off his face.
That's wonderful.
I know that it's just hard to get back into the sink.
I smash my finger in that.
It's a learning curve when you first start using the finger button too.
You must say yes.
The same thing.
Good thing is we don't have kids fall above them.
Yeah, one guys and this is our one does the math.
It looks like shortening how long it has.
So there's
I don't have to even know what else and visit them.
And I think that's the same car dealership on their property.
And then I don't have the papers up here for signature because I need a plan of non abstaining in that.
So I think that's what I'm saying.
I think that's what I'm saying.
Thank you very much.
I think that actually the way that it's on here.
I'm not sure.
Absolutely.
I think we have to play with that now.
I hope my job is spent at winning the seasons down.
I don't know about this.
Do you know why?
I don't know.
and then I'll just go to work downstairs.
Okay.
I'll send all of us.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
And that's it.
It's not funny.
It's not the big one.
That's what you're asking.
But look, see, that was a big thing.
That was a big one.
That was kind of a big one.
Thank you, it's weather.
This is happening from the Arcofen to very rivers, full, or at least that construction and place, comes in project.
Get me down to the wire.
Do you know how you all discussed that?
Does that took a bit more to be in this coming and it's very big, baby?
I do not know if we would have any big rivers, you know, we'd ask them for an email too.
That's why it was forwarded to me.
We have money left, Mark, a bunch, due to... That's our project left and we're good.
But let's hold this.
This one is another one.
Oh, give it to me.
This one here is a parallel group and here is on the center.
This one is the opposite.
This is, yes.
This one has to be over.
Thanks.
And then our portions like a thousand.
I've never done anything like that.
I'll do what she's made because I didn't know.
I'm not that bad.
I'm okay.
Hello, are you working?
I think he had a conversation.
Because he's getting at his hand.
That's what we did.
I think only one talk to him when he talks to him.
We did that.
I have another one last one, this is from California.
I'm going to switch in.
This is for, I'm going to set the switches for, but there's two in this one.
Okay.
And that concludes everything I have.
Yeah, I think that's our question.
Okay, so the only one you guys want me to hold the stop then and say, well, I'll talk to you now.
That's it.
There was a case.
I do have some of those things that I want to put back on.
These are all highlighted.
They're not closed, and they don't have to be closed anytime soon, but they do have to be too tricky.
And they do move.
Three of them have to be slated to move.
Thank you very much.
that, could that be done like the one that we just put in?
I'm fine.
I'm comparing this to any of the other batch.
Okay.
That's kind of the way I look at this one.
This may be the end of the batch.
Okay.
Because it's a long ridge across the fishing river which is wild.
And it's only a period of the military.
It's a period of time.
Out of dust, I do that.
I'm just telling you what I look at.
If you might have a little bit of a good time, close it.
I don't know.
So if you took that wrong, how does that affect those homes?
Well, for the people, does it?
It's all fun.
It's all done in the mountains.
It's the south.
We're going to go to the back of the way.
It's just a kind of man there.
It's huge.
You can get to all of these areas that check that.
I'm sure it's convenient for some people, but again, it's not taking dirt or trucks, it's not taking farm equipment.
But it's not quite a sand.
It's a three-toned one, which is partially different.
Even a heavy service truck probably shouldn't have done it because it would.
So that's going to be slated.
This one probably
But as you head into a corner, you can turn left on the tree and grab a little left of it without pulling it out.
Put it in the toilet.
Put it in the toilet
I don't go to New York.
I just don't know what it is.
Well, it doesn't go through the green bands.
It's, I'm just telling you that when you don't have a word to ask, it's something to get any drive by and to get it to the point, but to get it right to get it in order.
And all of these are in the far expression.
Yes.
And there's even one more way.
So we've got to find the important room.
All of them.
You know, I can be interesting when we have an election yesterday and there were special roads on there.
I know that there's always we are on a line where there's special on this side of the driveway and county on that side of the driveway.
and how they're talking something that I didn't know is where you
like your head.
So if you're head, get up.
And it wasn't.
It was counting instead of like, where your fat is straight out from there on your ground is, which takes stricter in.
Because I thought it was, I thought the way the other way.
So it's very confusing.
Women, those places, don't know.
Even if I move my bed, you're done in a dirty way.
You're in baby.
But I mean, we will get where's drones will be done this way, but it won't be done this way.
I mean, what are we doing with the reactors?
We can do whatever.
But I do want you to read this message from me, so you don't understand the people that they're needing.
Anything else?
This is just what we did.
I recently sent it to my home.
And next, I wonder, and you may already have done this, but you've been working on this.
About four more, we're looking at putting together the qualifications for that bridge, how far we can do this in.
And I'm going to give you four down, down there, forward, forward, forward, forward, forward to doing this bridge today.
Do you have any of them?
You may go to the center, I'll do that.
I thought we had to put that out to the engineer.
We were in her picture.
She got gone.
But not for the original.
needed to do something a little different, where we're asking what are your qualifications to represent us?
I thought I would not mind being at good resource jobs.
Is there anything else?
No questions.
I did have them.
So when you sell the old Humane Society building, those funds do they go to help fix the admin building, or is it going different?
since I couldn't hear we have not sold and I'm not sure, I would say it's different.
I would say it's different.
Then it'd probably be dispersed.
Okay.
I mean, that's basically what we get on the auction.
Right?
But we, you know, we sold all the old equipment and that went into the work where the equipment was put just from.
Yes.
And we have to be sure.
Make sense.
I'm about being here again five.
I'd like to move in.
I'd say maybe it's a joke.
We're all mean.
No, I'm up here because we have people down in the courthouse.
We're down in there.
Got anything to do?
The sign was posted right before the meeting.
If you have to hear a recording, you need to view, you need to view a record from the back view of the Commission as Office per state statute.
610.020.